for you like to come out and like have
that record like kind of be like a old
record that not necessarily old but a
record that had been out for a while but
really kind of like finally get some
life to it it's such a massive song the
remix was big it felt like such a big
moment um some people get a record like
that and it's like the music becomes
bigger the song becomes bigger bigger
than the artist how have you been able
to avoid that cuz I saw you you did my
club in a and and everybody was singing
all your [__] the thing about don't play
with it don't play with it went viral
not because of someone else did like a
viral Tik Tok to it it went viral
because of me being on screen performing
the song so thank God for that that
that's what made it take off it's seeing
me um perform it on from the Block yeah
I remember that and that's yeah shout to
from the block shout outs from the Block
what do they do with that mic is the mic
how they hang it do is it is it yeah is
it a ladder what's going on with that
it's like a little setup it's like you
know like what you use for like
backdrops I don't I mean I don't know
the proper word for it it's probably one
of those things but right and then it
just hangs yeah okay I always wondered I
was like do they got two ladders and
someone's just standing up I used to I
was wondering the same thing and then
when I got there I was like oh okay cool
this is cute um for you uh give me kind
of like a you know this is an important
album for you what is if someone were to
press play on this outside of the single
shout out to Bryson tiller you got the
brys but what what's your favorite song
what's like the go-to like what's the
song that embodies
Lola I am Lola embodies Lola that's the
intro yeah it's well it's it's not the
intro
but it it it it sounds like it could
have been the intro wait what's the
intro isn't the intro int is intro um
2023 flow oh maybe I'm tripping because
then I used to do these consistent
freestyles for my fans so I do 2017 flow
201 the ler record has like a sample
though kind of with your name in
it okay yeah yeah yeah so it's basically
me saying I'm the one like this is not a
mistake I'm a true artist I I I came
very far I spoke about where I'm coming
from how long I've worked how hard I've
worked and taking note for answer so
that embodies Lola for real I am Lola
give me some of the uh the the story
like how long has this cuz a lot of
people look at you like you're a new
artist but you ain't like you ain't new
to this like how long has this grind
been for you I'm not new I've been
working on music even let me just say
this 2017 is when I was like I'mma take
this serious serious like I resigned for
my job serious was that job residential
Aid at a shelter so I was just cat
catering to clients like homeless people
homeless people yeah and my mom got me
the job so [__] hits the you could
always move to LA and help us with this
homeless problem no for real and it's so
crazy I wanted to go back to the
facility that I was working at but they
closed it down oh damn yeah so that kind
of like broke my heart but my mom got me
the job there so I was explaining to her
like I always wanted to go back to give
back but they shut down the facility and
I don't know how I'mma get the names and
she was like she help me out you go down
to Downtown LA uh Skid Row tons of
giving back to do down there just you
got to dodge the fat and all smoke it's
rough down there it's rough like that oh
yeah it's bad [__] everywhere human [__]
everywhere fentanyl just I've never I've
seen it online cuz you know it's crazy
I've seen it online it's like The
Purge like we were driving down there
like last week mhm and like looked to
the right and there's just like five
fires in the middle of the
street like people warming their hands
and [__] like almost like a ninja turtle
movie like from the 90s you know like it
feels like the type of place Shredder
with um just like uh the movie Chucky
and it was a scene where it was like
homeless people warming up with um a
fire there lot scenes yeah like you know
like uh Joe pesi and home alone it's a
bunch of guys over there yeah but you
know see me growing up I'm thinking
that's like a old scenario but it's
still going on today oh it's lit over
here for sure crazy they just set the
freeway on fire the 10's closed down M
so if you ever have you tried to go
downtown since you've been in La I've
been downtown but I'm talking about this
trip like two days ago no no no no no
there was like an explosion under the
bridge like under the 10 and they they
vent they they think it some homeless
[__] going on under there that went
rough and then there was a big fire so
the freeways closed down indefinitely
the 10 in
La it's rough out here it's [__] up
yeah it's crazy yeah damn I'm going to
say this like I went to New York and
we're everywhere in New York I was like
yo it's nice out here I was like maybe
we saw like 12 homeless dudes it was
nice it's not no see compare La compared
to New York City yeah yeah you would be
like oh it's cool in New York but the
people that live in New York is like
it's certain places where do you guys
like Eric Adams the mayor like what is
he a nice guy like what are your
thoughts I've never met him but I mean
listen I just saw he was in like he had
to give his phone to the feds so I don't
know what's going on I peep that yeah I
peep that but Hey listen I just pray my
boy doing right by the city me too he
seems like he's
like yeah but um
everybody everybody have their way of
showing um who they are and I just pray
that whatever he got going on he could
defend himself we just went on a wild
tangent because you're explaining to me
you quit your job in 2017 and then we
started talking about fed continue your
story 2017 you quit your job 2017 you
did it 27 2017 I quit my job February
14th I resign I didn't quit hold on
let's fix that I did not quit my job I
resigned from my job so if I wanted to
go back to my job today I can good okay
right I don't burn Bridges regardless of
what's my journey or what I feel like my
future is to to bring um I don't burn
Bridges you know what I'm saying so yeah
I resigned from my job my mom actually
supported me through it nice she was
like look listen I see you going in and
out the house no sleep Studio work if
you feel like you need to leave so that
you could really dig down into your your
Artistry do so and she got me the job so
it was a it I just felt like it was arms
opened for her to say because
you know when it come down to Mommy
every you get a little I did not just
make them calls get you that job for you
for you to quit right right right right
so I'm like all right she said we just
going to do it the right way you going
to resign and then my mentor 80 shout
outs to team 80 he supported me too
financially as well so so what was like
I had to go support system after you
went all time like fulltime rather how
long did it take for you to realize like
uh you could make this your career like
you could actually like oh this is
working like I made some money I got
paid to do this like maybe you got paid
to do a future maybe you got paid to do
a show or uh it wasn't money for me it
was just how it made me feel
so my teammate that's a part of Team 80
his name is bzy he's an artist from
Brownsville he wanted to do Brownville
shout out to Brownsville it's rough out
in Browns if you should they should have
took you to Brownsville it's still
Brownsville never Chang I've heard
that's the only place that hasn't been
gentrified yeah in Brownsville Brooklyn
New York it's crazy out there but Fame
and Billy Dan just hanging out on the
corner still it's wow no for real like
it's out there like nothing has changed
I think um 41's from there right the 41
people uh uh I think but I don't want to
be I don't want to say so and then but I
know it's Brooklyn for sure so he asked
to get me on a song for a feature I came
through you had 8 there Uncle M was
there shout out to Uncle Mayo uh and you
say uncle Mayo yeah I call him Uncle M
he's a nice Uncle yeah he is a nice
Uncle he's crazy though so I did the
song I ended up meeting the team which
is team I met everybody and I just fell
in love with just being in the studio
because where I came from I I couldn't
afford studio time I couldn't afford
videos I wasn't even thinking about
doing videos cuz I ain't I wasn't
financially stable to do so and I just
was around it I just felt good I'm like
yo you know what this could be this
could be a thing for me and then my my
dad just had passed and um I remember my
best friend saying like you was you
you're depressed I didn't know I was
depressed but she was like you're
depressed and ever since you start
taking music serious like you like you
shift it's kind of made you happy yes it
made me happy so being around them made
me so happy just seeing ad put his
artist DOD was his art his artist he put
them through artist development did
music videos um in a studio night and
day going out to the clubs promoting
music and I never got to see that part
of it so I'm like oh this is this is
fire but it was no M I wasn't making no
money it just was something to you saw
the light at the end of the tone you're
like oh this is yeah yeah so then yeah I
tapped into it like that